Shayne Irving joining us after at Bing
win last night how about them cowboy
madam you're back you're ready they're
breathing little CPR last night okay but
you look at the schedule here all right
it's not death it's bad Danny it's a
tougher schedule than anybody else
sitting at 500 right now looking for the
playoffs okay you're at the Giants who
knows what you're getting you're at
Oakland who knows what you're getting
host Seattle and then at Philly and who
knows that filly needs that winter not
Kenzie comes back after two more right
yes okay if if the ginger can actually
see what happened last night and follow
the script this is what makes me so mad
Danny it ain't complicated right no and
the mans overeducated Alfred Morris had
what five yards of carry well you ran
the ball 40 times and you win the damn
game that's just how it goes that's why
that's how this team is built just play
to your frickin strengths Danny but they
did well with the defense they had some
turnovers she had a punt return so it
was a total team effort dak didn't play
great but he was he was good he was
economical that busted him might have
been the best thing that happened so
they weren't he couldn't throw damn ball
thank God
how you gonna make deck Prescott a
sophomore quarterback from Mississippi
State who didn't exactly air it out in
the SEC how you gonna make him pretend
like he's the next Tony Romo would have
him checking down on the line and
pretending like he's got the whole
offense just won the damn ball just run
the damn ball I want you to look at this
bet we have a shower of shame coming up
man it's mclovin and Seaton and they
have a bet with games coming up this
weekend not that you're good at picking
games well I want you to listen to what
this bed is McLovin would you run down
what you and Seaton have at stake for a
shower of shame with games then we'll
get to Jay's picks so I have a lot of
underdogs Seaton has the top four teams
in the current college football rankings
which are Clemson Auburn Oklahoma
Wisconsin and then I gave him what I
thought was two favorites in the NFL the
Eagles and the Vikings but as it turns
out the Vikings are not favorites so I
have all these underdogs see them as
them all whoever wins more games
doesn't have to go in the shower shame I
don't know if you really captured the
essence you know that there this is a
money on bet Danny it's just to work
money not just win yeah just straight up
that's pretty dumb nerd like do you do
you like seat inside of this oh yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah
it's money long bed you taking home
favorites man let's go well he he's up
for one well I would gladly do the
points but the way it works around here
nobody does a straight up bet like that
you have to give a little juice to get
and you you're doing a straight a match
when you say straight up bet that's what
you're doing right now I know but they
won't they won't know that this point
actually obscene if you want the Vegas
lines you're good
alright we've so you're siding with
Seton yes you yeah I'm good that's I
don't know anything about anything yes I
just said okay
yeah McLovin picked all the games there
all right so uh che this is from not
last week the week before yeah yeah you
went 1-4 and one over the last week I
went 3 & 2 2 & 3 - okay yeah it's on the
Internet and then of course do you have
a bet for the front row yeah oh you do I
do okay you pitch it um front rows
taking the turnover chain plus 9 you got
Miami plus 9 against Clemson mm-hmm I
got Clemson - not okay Paulie
front row interested in that not even
close - interested Wow
so it's a good what about you taking the
Badgers plus six Bullock oh god that's
saucy first half three and a half you
like Wisconsin Poland will take
Wisconsin getting the chips if you allow
us to have a burn out right over George
no way no no way I got Auburn I'm heavy
on Auburn Jarek stidham's a genius y'all
gotta let him air it out that man was
throwing passes in Waco in a practice
field last year he's going the NFL we'll
take we'll put a hundred on Wisconsin
getting the chips okay plus six yeah
sure why not
let's go urban no more heart attacks
hey it's good to see I'm glad your
Cowboys are still alive I don't know
about all that dating now they're alive
they're breathing they're breathing the
problem is if the ginger stays what
would I want do I want a first round
exit or the playoffs we're all one if
that meant you lost Jason Garrett I'd
rather not go to the playoffs if it
means I'll lose Jason Garrett and Jerry
steps down as general manager
well that's unhappen detail that's not
yeah all right we'll come back we'll
close up shop here Dan in the Danette
Stan Patrick show four more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show ass
[Music]